说话人 1: 欢迎来到真实社交，我是Jackson
说话人 1: 今天给大家带来一期技术点很多，时间线也很长，技巧点超级多的聊天的案例
说话人 1: 这个女生她是一个岁数比较大，价值观非常的普信，非常的普世价值观，有一点点女权，她身边以前
说话人 1: 接触的男的，可能都是属于框架很弱，比较安全，比较乖的男生
说话人 1: 所以咱们给他的一个冲击力是非常的大的，也会有很多的一个碰撞，有很多的火花，处理了很多问题，互相适应对方的一个节奏
说话人 1: 大家可以看一下一个具体的一个操作与思维逻辑
说话人 1: OK，这里通过微信之后，她直接给我发了名字过来，因为我搭讪的时候跟她说了一句话，你要把你的名字发我，测试了一个服从性，因为是有吸引，有窗口，我们已经聊出窗口来了，聊出吸引来了，所以说她会直接发给我她的名字，服从性也是很好的，这是一个比较好的一个信号，但是仅此而已，比较好的信号，她不是已经喜欢你了
说话人 1: 我们也是用了一个同理心开场，是不是有点突然
说话人 1: 我是姐姐
说话人 1: 他说是有一点，表示理解
说话人 1: 他表示
说话人 1: 理解我，确实有点突然，但是也还好
说话人 1: 这一句话，有勇气是好事情
说话人 1: OK，已经闻到什么味道了，已经是一个废物测试给丢过来了，他在让你去复格，你有勇气是追逐他的一个位置
说话人 1: OK，咱们直接不接这个东西
说话人 1: 我说男生想认识女生很正常啊，认识又不代表什么，我只是过来认识你而已，不一定非要怎么样，我是
说话人 1: 有勇气，但不是只是对你一个人有勇气，或者说我不是他们的很鼓足勇气来认识你，你不一定有那么值得，就给他表示出这样一个态度，让他知道这个男人不是他们的舔狗，不是一只大舔狗
说话人 1: 这一句，但我觉得你性格还可以，温柔型
说话人 1: OK，这里我在筛选她，让她副格，因为我觉得可以的类型是那种温柔型，让她自己变成那个类型
说话人 1: OK，这里她说不代表什么呀，兄弟们，你看女人，她是天生的PUA，她的嗅觉能闻到你的一些浅沟通，知道吧
说话人 1: 直接给你破解掉，她也在抵抗，不进入你的框架，因为这样会显得很廉价
说话人 1: 这一句相信你的感觉，她引用了我这个问题
说话人 1: 就温柔型的问题
说话人 1: 她已经在给她自己复格了，我是喜欢那种温柔型的，她说她自己刚好是温柔型
说话人 1: OK，这个时候咱们也不要表现出马上就对她有兴趣了，还很早，这个时间点还很早，咱们不能马上表现出对她有兴趣，所以我给了一个推拉，我说虽然还算温柔，但是咱们还不够了解嘛
说话人 1: 这句话表示出咱们是一个有态度，有选择
说话人 1: 有标准的一个男人，而不是他们的，你温柔我就马上要舔上来，不是那个意思
说话人 1: 他回了一个，了解一个人是需要很长的时间的，大家感觉一下这是什么意思
说话人 1: 如果是你们来回，你们会怎么回
说话人 1: 很多人可能是，哦，对，是确实要很长时间，哦，对对对，你说的没错，我也觉得
说话人 1: OK，那你就先输一局
说话人 1: 他这句话的意思是
说话人 1: 什么
说话人 1: 他的意思是，你要跟我成为男女的关系，你要跟我在一起，是需要很长的时间的一个投资，又要时间，可能又要金钱，又要你的情绪，又要你的情感投资，他是在引诱去投资
说话人 1: OK，咱们直接不接，咱们直接反驳，我说我不认同，不真实的人一辈子都会带着面具，让你了解不了
说话人 1: 因为确实是这个道理，如果是你
说话人 1: 这个人在装，你这个人装着，非要我了解你，用很长时间，那我一辈子都了解不了你
说话人 1: 直接把他的逻辑给干碎，直接把他的框架给干碎
说话人 1: 他这里也在说，他说那肯定的
说话人 1: 你想他自己才说的一个东西，马上他们的又被我给击碎了，他还来赞同我
说话人 1: 你说女人是不是就喜欢胡说八道
说话人 1: 这里他马上又发了一句，但是也要那个人愿意被你了解，是不
说话人 1: 他这句话是什么意思
说话人 1: 她又在那里装，又在那里装逼
说话人 1: 首先这个女人她是对咱们有兴趣的，但是她要装矜持，因为像这种岁数的女生，她的选择就比较狭窄了，因为她年龄比较大了，所以说她的选择是比较尖锐的，这就是咱们为什么嗅觉要非常的灵敏，咱们技巧要非常的好，这类女生你才干得住
说话人 1: 如果这是一个大学生，或者说这是一个学生妹， 23 以下或者 22 以下，已经倍感住了，已经倍感住了，如果是同样的
说话人 1: 如果他是同样的一个情绪，他已经倍感住了
说话人 1: 但是这个女人她不会，她的理性的东西要占据的更多，知道吧
说话人 1: 就算她的情
说话人 1: 绪很好，就算他的情绪很好，他也要用脑子去思考一些东西了，才会做一些决定
说话人 1: 所以说这就体现咱们技术的一个重要性，一个框架的一个重要性
说话人 1: 我说那肯定就没必要浪费时间在没必要的事情上了呀
说话人 1: 我这句话的意思是，如果说你装逼，那我们就不要浪费时间
说话人 1: 我说对抗世界是需要我们，而不是我
说话人 1: 这句话的意思是，如果只是我
说话人 1: 我一个人想见的话，那就没有必要，必须你也想见，我也想见，才可以见
说话人 1: 这个女的她说刚才在吃饭聊天，不好意思没回复你
说话人 1: 首先从这两句话我们可以判断出这个女人她是一个很假礼貌、假客气，因为她的生活圈子全是假人，全是装逼的
说话人 1: 会影响他的一个假礼貌，但是我们不 care 这个
说话人 1: 还有一个意思是不好意思没回复你，也确实能知道他的心里是有咱们的一块地方，他还在意你这个人，这个意思
说话人 1: 你想，如果说他不在意你这个人，他不会跟你说不好意思
说话人 1: 女人如果说对你没有兴趣，她不会对你礼貌，连对你礼貌的机
说话人 1: 会都没有，这个你们得注意一下
说话人 1: 这里他说不好意思没回复你，因为刚才在吃饭聊天
说话人 1: 那个时候我已经睡觉了，我就没有理他
说话人 1: 第二天也是，我上午健完身，我才开始跟他确定一些东西
说话人 1: 我直接直奔主题，你最近哪天可以有时间
说话人 1: 记住我这个字，哪天可以有
说话人 1: 什么意思
说话人 1: 如果你正常发的话
说话人 1: 你最近哪天有时间
说话人 1: 他可能回的是一个很装逼，有空再说，到时候再说，我也不知道，可能会是这种类似的一个回复
说话人 1: 我为什么要加个可以有
说话人 1: 这个可以有的意思就是让他不要他们的装逼，给我一个落实，给我一个确定好的一个时间
说话人 1: 你最近哪天可以有时间，知道吧
说话人 1: 意思是完全他们的不一样的
说话人 1: 现在给到你们话术，惯例
说话人 1: 他说喝咖啡，我说差不多吧，下午茶
说话人 1: 兄弟们，你要知道我如果在聊天上，我每一句话都是有意义的，都不是他们的废话
说话人 1: 我为什么要说差不多吧，下午茶
说话人 1: 是想给他说，我不一定他们的请你是喝咖啡，因为那个太单调了，因为如果说你
说话人 1: 你每次都约咖啡，他重复还在问你，你还说约咖啡，这样会很单调
说话人 1: 所以说我说差不多吧，下午茶
说话人 1: 还有一个意思就是我是想见你这个人，喝什么东西、吃什么东西、玩什么东西无所谓，是对你人有兴趣，是这个意思
说话人 1: 他这里问，他说你住哪里呀
说话人 1: 很多嗅觉不灵敏的兄弟，他可能认为女生在问他住哪里，就只是这样而已
说话人 1: 但其实他如果说这句话的意思，就是他已经承认这次邀约了，他已经答应这次邀约了
说话人 1: 如果说她问你住哪里，你就可以直接安排地点、时间，直接见面了，就是这个意思
说话人 1: 所以我这里直接问她，我说我大坪，你呢
说话人 1: 她说你这个回消息有点不礼貌哦
说话人 1: 我说没有，想多了，在忙而已
说话人 1: 她可能觉得在装逼，我因为我确实没有看到那个消息
说话人 1: 我是问你是住哪
说话人 1: 他就
说话人 1: 就说我就住在新牌坊这边，我们做的事情永远是一个调度，永远是一个安排时间、安排地点
说话人 1: 我说观音桥可以吗
说话人 1: 他说都行
说话人 1: 兄弟们，你们看到我有没有，诶，你问地点干嘛
说话人 1: 你住哪
说话人 1: 我住哪
说话人 1: 就没了
说话人 1: 如果说是你们来的话，你们回答了地方，回答了什么，就没了
说话人 1: 你要知道你要去主动安排这个东西，而不是让女人来安排这个东西
说话人 1: 你们可以看到
说话人 1: 这个东西的浅沟通是有多强
说话人 1: 里面暗藏的意思是有多少
说话人 1: 里面暗藏的意思有很多，而你们都读不到这个东西，这就是你们欠缺的
说话人 1: 所以还在那里为什么约不出来
说话人 1: 还在那里这个女生为什么不理我
说话人 1: 是因为你就只会聊，你必须找一个会的人，手把手的指导你，你才能真正体验到那种感觉，而不是他们的哪句话说
说话人 1: 哪个惯例把女人给干住，知道吧
说话人 1: OK，这里咱们已经确定了地点，马上要确定一下时间，我问她，我说你说个可以的时间，我的话一般是下午 4 点后
说话人 1: 这里我再给大家一个点，首先我让这个女人她有选择的一定的空间，这是给她一个很好的一个尊重
说话人 1: 我也会有自己的一个标准，我说我的话一般是下午 4 点后，你们看表面上是我在问她时间是什么时候可以约，但实际上是我在定时间，因为我说的是下午 4 点后才可以约，懂了没有
说话人 1: 脑子里懂了没有
说话人 1: 这个逻辑
说话人 1: 她说 4 点就不是喝下午茶嘞，这个女人她有点扯淡啊，她反正总喜欢跟你唱反调
说话人 1: 因为他想测试你这个人到底是不是你表
说话人 1: 表现出来的那么
说话人 1: 如果说你们再怎么能装，装到我这个时间点了，很可能女生几句话引起你的情绪波动，你就装不下去了，你就开始舔上去了，那么你前面做的东西全白费，女的瞬间就会觉得是个下头男，瞬间把你删掉
说话人 1: 嘿嘿，所以兄弟们，装是没有用的，你必须自己有那么才行，自己脑子里的东西有那么多，自己知道应该该怎么做，自己
说话人 1: 知道女性，女人她不是稀缺的东西，你们自己要有这种富足的一个心态，这样才能把到正妹
说话人 1: 我这里我直接推刀，我说不重要啊，跟想见的人散步喝茶都没区别
说话人 1: 我是以人为本，我跟你见面的话，哪怕我们可以去吃臭豆腐，哪怕我们可以去吃小面，哪怕我们饿着肚子一起淋雨，都OK，只要我对你这个人感兴趣
说话人 1: 这里他还在装逼，他说我能说我有点社恐
说话人 1: 懂吗
说话人 1: 昨天没看出来我很害羞吗
说话人 1: 女人她是一个只会推卸责任的一个物种，她永远需要人去保护她，把所有的东西给扛住
说话人 1: 你如果扛不住这个东西，这个女人就不会跟你见面
说话人 1: 所以咱们要读出她的一个顾虑，不要用逻辑去干住她，哎呀，没事，你出来嘛，哎呀，没事，有用吗
说话人 1: 没卵用，知道吗
说话人 1: 咱们要解决问
说话人 1: 我说，你知道我不是个尴尬的人，所以我们交流不会出现你认为的一个情况
说话人 1: OK，这句话直接干住她
说话人 1: OK，她说看出来了
说话人 1: 这个时候她就已经知道跟我约会，跟我做什么都很安全，都不会有很恶心的情况出现，都不会有下头的情况出现
说话人 1: 她说你昨天跟你哥们在那里干嘛呢
说话人 1: 看到没有
说话人 1: 这个女人
说话人 1: 真的是，她身边的舔狗屌丝绝对非常的多，因为她随口都能抛出一个很屌的一个废物测试
说话人 1: 我敢说这句话， 99% 的兄弟都不知道这句话是什么意思
说话人 1: 就这句话，你昨天跟你哥们在那里干嘛呢
说话人 1: 因为当时我是跟我的僚机在那里站着，我给他说我们是在等人，但是我搭讪又把他搭的吸引很强，所以说他会觉得不太真实，感觉像演的
说话人 1: 从来没有人他们的可以这么屌，可以站在他面前把他给勾住，又不舔，又不是很凶，在中间一直稳定的那条线，他从来没有见过，所以说他会非常奇怪，怎么会有这种人
说话人 1: 这句话的意思就是，这个女人她的嗅觉，她的直觉非常的灵敏，她会感觉说我太熟练了，可能是专职业搭讪
说话人 1: 或者是那种情场
说话人 1: 老手，反正她感觉不太正常，所以这里咱们马上就要给一个舒适感，把她的这种心情给她压下去
说话人 1: 我说只是我比较有勇气，我说感觉在拷问我
说话人 1: OK，这里咱们又做了一个失格，又做了一个情绪波动，女生马上又跳起来了情绪
说话人 1: 就这个女生，她在跟我聊天的时候，永远在坐过山车，这就是为什么你们聊的很平
说话人 1: 行，女生不愿意出来见你，因为她感觉不到情绪，你要给她情绪
说话人 1: 她说我聊天没什么拷问，你不要想多了
说话人 1: 与其说拷问，你还不如换个话说
说话人 1: 她这里又在解释一大堆，其实我就是开个玩笑，我说感觉在拷问，她解释一大堆
说话人 1: 就这个女人她确实已经完全被我的框架给压制住了，但她的本能感觉又不能让自己
说话人 1: 太随便，太顺从，所以说他会有这种很情绪化，很没有逻辑的一些语言出现，这是咱们非常喜欢看到的一些东西
说话人 1: OK，但是咱们不跟他扯淡，还是回到主题，邀约，我说出来瞅瞅就真相大白了，什么有没有勇气啊
说话人 1: 你的朋友在干嘛啊
说话人 1: 那些玩意都不重要，你只要出来见我，你只要出来跟我见面，什么都知道了，就不用
说话人 1: 在微信上废话那么多，我就是这个意思
说话人 1: 她说我忙完了呀，她这句话的意思是，她现在可以跟我见了，但是那个时候已经 4 点多了，我那个时候手里还有事，也没有时间去见她
说话人 1: 我说不如明天，我不会急着非要把这个女人先给见了，你的需求感一定要自己控制一下，我不是在控制，我是本身他们的就没有啥需求感，只是想见她，但是不
说话人 1: 不是很想见她的那种感觉，你不需要那么急迫，但这个东西你不能装出来，是因为我本身不急迫，因为我手里，我有很多女生可以转盘子，我有很多女生可以见，所以说我不急
说话人 1: 但是如果是你们装出来不急的那个样子，女生的，别说这个女生，就是大学生，小一点的，情感经历稍微少一点的，女生，她都能闻得出来你是在装
说话人 1: 所以这个东西你只能去扩大你的一个盘子数量，才能真正的切实的解决这个问题
说话人 1: 她说后面再说吧，明天我不一定
说话人 1: 就这个女的，她的社交直觉非常的强，一旦你的框架把她给挤压住，让她感觉不舒服了，她马上就会框架给你推回来
说话人 1: 你知道我们一直是在进行一个博弈的一个状态，每时每刻，只要跟她说话的每时每刻，一直在博弈
说话人 1: 非常有意思啊，这个女生非常的让我感觉有难度
说话人 1: 实话实说，很多女生聊着没啥难度，三两下就给约出来了
说话人 1: 这个问题那么多，我还比较喜欢这种感觉
说话人 1: 我说OK，今天确实有点仓促了
说话人 1: 她说没有没有，只是我这会在观音桥的
说话人 1: 她随时随地要表现出她很无所谓，她见不见你都OK
说话人 1: 女人她是随时随地都能表现出她的一个无所谓的
说话人 1: 她的一个无需求的一个态度的，你们要知道女人她在面对星语，她在面对男人的时候，能有多克制
说话人 1: 就是 10 个你都达不到的一个境界
说话人 1: 我稍微好一点，我可能五个我都达不到的境界，就对于异性的一个自制力，但是我可以用脑子把她给控制住
说话人 1: 女人一旦情绪化上来了之后，她跟男人他们的没什么区别
说话人 1: 我这
说话人 1: 这里废话不多说，直接发了一个捂脸的表情，让他知道我的心情
说话人 1: 他马上，这个表情就表达了很多东西，表达了我的不满意，我对你这个人装逼有些意见
说话人 1: 他马上开始自我解释，我的意思就是我随口这么一说，不是让你今天，懂了吧
说话人 1: 你知道吗
说话人 1: 这种口气就像他们的，我举个例子，就像我是一个正媒，这个女的是你们
说话人 1: 你们面对正妹的时候在舔的口气，你们脑子里又在想，我不能这么舔，我不能这么舔，就装成这种话，这几句话就感觉他们的很怪
说话人 1: 就这个女人，她明明很想见，明明对你这个人就有意思，但是她又要装的没那么有意思，但是她装的又不是很像，就导致了现在这么一种感觉，就很扯淡
说话人 1: 我这里直接切入主题，我说但我不希望你只是嘴炮，因为我想有一些确信感，让她真正的记住这个邀约的一个东西，让她记住我们约咖啡的这个东西，而不是他们的只是说着玩
说话人 1: 她说换个词，嘴炮都来了
说话人 1: 就这个女生非常的，可能非常的传统，非常的，可能带点女权，因为她说的那些话都很假，很礼貌，嘴炮都来了
说话人 1: 就明明很真实的一个表达，她说嘴炮都来了
说话人 1: 我没理他，我说江渝女生大多都水，深有体会
说话人 1: 只是这里我有
说话人 1: 其实这里我又是在给她表达，我平时可能见的女生很多，我身边女生很多，又说她很水，就有这两个意思
说话人 1: 这个女生我不知道她是没 get 到，还是她的注意力在水那边，所以说她说这话说的，我让你过来，你又说太仓促
说话人 1: 兄弟们看到没有
说话人 1: 她是想见我的，但是她非要说让你过来
说话人 1: 反正很有意思，这个女的
说话人 1: 这一套
说话人 1: 回又说我水，这里我说这种话见的太多了，他说后面空了再说吧，这种话我说我见的太多了
说话人 1: 第一，我想表达你这样说空了再说这种话，对于我来说是很没有意义的，很水的一种感觉，这本来就是一个事实
说话人 1: 第二点，这种话见的太多了，意思是我身边还是有很多女生在沟通、在接触
说话人 1: 我马上说不一定
说话人 1: 要现在，只是想有确定感
说话人 1: 其实我这个话的意思是，我说不一定非要现在，只是想让你把这件事印入你的脑子里，你要知道有这件事，而不是敷衍
说话人 1: 他说sorry，那我换句话
说话人 1: 他发了这句话，实际上是很大的一个推，因为他可能理解错了，他说只是想有确定感，那个确定感是我一定非要怎么样，非要把她当成女朋友去发展，非要把她当成什么跑友去发展，非要跟她发生什么关系
说话人 1: 其实不是那个意思，我是要跟她确定邀约的那个意思，她可能理解错了
说话人 1: 但是因为当时咱们有点忙，也没有管她了，就直接把她给放下了
说话人 1: 然后经过了 5 天，我才想起她了，我再去做的后面的一个处理，才把她给约出来了
说话人 1: 下面那部分我会另外做一期节目，把它给呈现出来
说话人 1: 这次就先只做上半部分，因为已经很长了